das sind keine guten nachrichten der
jupiter schleudert offenbar asteroiden
in richtung erde das sagen neue studien
demnach könnte jupiter als eine art
scharfschütze fungieren und objekte
aktiv in unsere richtung schleudern ist
der größte planet unseres sonnensystems
also eine gefahr für die erde klicks
umsatz im flugzeug gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos aber
nicht den kanal und aktiviert die glocke
nur so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ihr könnt euch
übrigens noch zuverlässiger informieren
lassen über unsere talibangruppe da
bekommt ihr in jedem fall unabhängig vom
youtube algorithmus meine videos früher
und vor allem zuverlässig mit einer
nachricht und ihr könnt mit diskutieren
und dem vorschlagen der link ist hier
unter me und unten in der video
beschreibung der gasriese jupiter als
großer beschützer der erde
forschungsteams weltweit gingen lange
zeit davon aus dass dieser planet
entscheidend zu der lebens
freundlichkeit der erde beiträgt die
rede ist von der sogenannten jupiter
spieltheorie demnach fungiert der
gasriese als schutzschild für unsere
erde nach ansicht der fachleute führt
jupiters großer masse nämlich dazu dass
asteroiden und kometen von ihrer bahn
abgelenkt werden demnach könnten so in
der vergangenheit katastrophale
produktion im inneren sonnensystem
verhindert werden seine gewaltige
gravitationskraft könnte jupiter also zu
einem kosmischen staubsauger machen der
viele umherwandern der gesteinsbrocken
an und auf sich zieht oder diese in den
äußeren bereich des sonnensystems
katapultiert astronomie teams weltweit
wissen schon seit langer zeit dass
allein die existenz von jupiter das
sonnensystem zu dem machte was es heute
ist der gasriese ist wohl so etwas wie
der unumstrittene könig des
sonnensystems und er bricht in vielen
hinsichten rekorde
er ist nicht nur größer und massereicher
als die anderen planeten nach der sonder
verfügt er auch über die größte
anziehungskraft aller körper in unserem
sonnensystem erst in diesen tagen hat
ein us forschungsteam eine aktuelle
studie veröffentlicht nach der der
jupiter einen tödlichen stoß effekt auf
die venus ausgeübt haben könnte und
unser nachbar planet war in seiner
anfangszeit der lebensfreude die und
möglicherweise sogar über ozeane verfügt
haben mittlerweile ist die venus
allerdings eine einzige flutwelle und
daran könnte der jupiter schuld sein
denn sein gewaltiger schwerkraft
einfluss könnte dafür gesorgt haben dass
sich die umlaufbahn der jungen venus
verändert hat modellsimulationen
jedenfalls weisen darauf hin dass ihr
orbit exzentrischer wurde und sich die
einst lebensfreundliche venus rasant
erwärmt hat und auch auf unsere erde hat
der jupiter auswirkung gar keine frage
vom geht jupiter als eine art bodyguard
für die erde oder geht von ihm auch für
uns eine bedrohung aus klar ist
jedenfalls dass hier in der
vergangenheit vergleichsweise viele
einschläge beobachtet werden konnten
schätzungen zufolge passiert ist alle
zehn bis 15 jahre da ist ein objekt der
größe zwischen 500 metern und einem
kilometer auf dem gasriesen einschlägt
nehmen objekte ein solches ende sind sie
jedenfalls nicht mehr gefährlich für die
erde schließlich gelangen sie so nicht
weiter in das innere sonnensystem so zum
beispiel der fall vor acht jahren 2012
und vor elf jahren 2009 als größere
objekte auf jupiter treffen
mittlerweile weiß man dass es sich im
jahr 2009 wohl um einen asteroiden
gehandelt haben muss infrarot aufnahmen
der nasa zeigt die atmosphäre des
jupiters der einschlag des asteroiden
wurde sichtbar als heller fleck in der
nähe des südpols zunächst gingen die
fachleute davon aus dass es sich damals
um einen kometeneinschlag gehandelt
haben muss doch die genaue analyse von
temperatur und anderen daten legte offen
dass es sich eher um einen asteroiden
gehandelt haben muss diese besitzen
anders als kometen weniger bis keine
flüchtigen stoffe und bilden daher auch
keinen schweiß die new york times
schrieb damals das ist jupiter der
seinen kosmischen job macht anteil
dessen was die erde zu einem solchen
netten ort zum leben macht allein
deshalb weil jupiters erhebliche
schwerkraft als gravitations schild
fungiert der ankommenden weltraummüll
hauptsächlich kometen vom inneren
sonnensystem ablegt spektakulär war auch
der crash von shoemaker levy 9
der crash wurde 1994
von irdischen teleskopen verfolgt
zunächst brach in 21 teile und dann
verschwand der komet shoemaker levy 9
stück für stück in der atmosphäre des
jupiters doch unser angeblicher retter
der gasriese jupiter kann möglicherweise
auch ganz anders darauf weisen immer
mehr untersuchungen und studien demnach
könnte jupiter sogar zum todesengel für
die erde werden
fest steht jedenfalls zwischen den
umlaufbahnen von mars und jupiter gibt
es eine riesige menge an kleineren und
auch größeren gesteinsbrocken
normalerweise sollten diese asteroiden
auch genau dort bleiben und brav die
sonne umkreisen im sogenannten
asteroidengürtel
doch manchmal kommt es vor dass
asteroiden aus ihrer bahn geworfen
werden beispielsweise durch koalitionen
untereinander und dann nehmen sie ihren
ganz eigenen schicksals weg durch das
sonnensystem wäre die erde also schon
viel häufiger von großen asteroiden
getroffen worden wenn es jupiter nicht
gäbe viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass die
existenz eines solchen riesenplaneten
jupiter der kosmischen nachbarschaft
tatsächlich dafür notwendig ist dass auf
einem planeten überhaupt höhere
lebensformen entstehen können denn eine
langfristige evolution hat nun mal wenig
sinn wenn ihr immer wieder durch
asteroiden anschläge ein strich durch
die rechnung gemacht wird so wie damals
vor 65 millionen jahren als die
dinosaurier ausstarben und zahlreiche
beobachtungen zeigen tatsächlich das
erdähnliche planeten häufig einen großen
beschützer haben dennoch wird in
fachkreisen eine frage noch immer stark
diskutiert ist die zusammensetzung und
anordnung von planetensystemen eher
zufällig oder er ist sie das ergebnis
einer entwicklung von planetensystemen
die nach bestimmten gesetzmäßigkeiten
abläuft eine super spannende
forschungsfrage und ein internationales
forschungsteam hat nun herausgefunden
dass die verteilung von gesteins gas und
eisplaneten wohl kaum dem zufall zu
verdanken ist die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler um martin schlecker
vom max planck institut für astronomie
in heidelberg gehen stattdessen davon
aus dass nur wenige anfangsbedingungen
entscheidend dafür sind wie sich
planetensysteme entwickeln ihre
simulation offenbaren die folgenden
also demnach produzieren vor allem
planetensysteme mit sonnenähnlichen
sternen die im innenbereich supererden
mit geringem wasser um gasgehalt
hervorbringen jupiter ähnlichen planeten
der aktuellen studie zufolge treten
gesteinsplaneten ähnlich der erde
weiterhin auffällig oft zusammen mit
einem planeten auf der sich auf einem
weiten orbit befindet und als jupiter
ähnlich zu beschreiben ist dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam solche gasriesen
nennen wir kalte jupiter sie entwickeln
sich in einem abstand vom zentralgestirn
wo wasser in form von eis vorliegt an
diese ergebnisse gelangten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
durch die statistische auswertung von
simulationen diese zeigen wie sich 1000
planetensysteme in einer protoplanetaren
scheibe um einen sonnenähnlichen stern
entwickeln die anfangsbedingungen dabei
wurden variiert beispielsweise was die
massen von gas und fester materie sowie
die position der kanzel neuer planeten
angeht den lebenszyklus dieser systeme
analysierte das forschungsteam in den
modellen über mehrere milliarden jahre
hinweg dazu der berner wissenschaftler
christof moser sie nie dabei sammelten
die planetaren embryos material
anwuchsen zum planeten heran änderten
ihre bahnen kollidierten oder wurden aus
dem system heraus geschleudert das
ergebnis der studie ist eindeutig
demnach gab es einen deutlichen überhang
an planetensystemen zu verzeichnen in
denen sich sowohl ein kalter jupiter als
auch mindestens eine trockene supererde
mit nur wenig wasser bzw eis und einer
höchstens dünnen atmosphäre befindet die
endgültige konzentration der
planetensysteme ist in simulationen
zufolge vor allem von der masse der
protoplanetaren scheibe abhängig damit
ist diejenige masse gemeint die für die
aktion also für das anwachsen von
planeten zur verfügung steht also die
masse quasi von allem was dann um diesen
zentralen stern kreist diese ergebnisse
sollen schon bald überprüft werden doch
die bislang zur verfügung stehenden
messinstrumente sind dafür nicht
empfindlich genug und so wird auf den
start von zwei sehr leistungsstarken
teleskopen gewartet
noch in diesem jahrzehnt sollen nämlich
dass extremely large telescope vlt der
europäischen südsternwarte in betrieb
gehen und das james webb space telescope
der nasa
soll gestartet werden also dass et wird
in chile in betrieb genommen also auf
der erde und das cabrio sc so heißt das
james webb weltraumteleskop abgekürzt
wird auf einem punkt jenseits des mondes
im weltraum positioniert dazu der
forscher martin schlecker theoretische
vorhersagen müssen an der erfahrung
scheitern können mit den kurz vor dem
einsatz stehenden instrumenten der
nächsten generation werden wir prüfen
können ob unser modell standhält oder
wird zurück ans zeichenbrett müssen
falls sich die ergebnisse des
internationalen forschungsteams dann
bestätigen wäre es also kein zufall dass
sich im sonnensystem neben der erde an
planet wie jupiter befindet doch wie
schon angedeutet häufen sich die
hinweise darauf dass jupiter nicht nur
retter sondern auch todesengel spielen
könnte bereits vor zwölf jahren 2008
hatte der amerikanischen planeten
physiker kevin mazur
durch die analyse von
computersimulationen hinweise auf ein
ambivalentes verhalten von jupiter
entdeckt der jupiter ist also ein
zweischneidiges schwert er zählt zu den
größten kritikern der jupiter schied
theorie und herr jupiter stadt einen
schutzschild für ein zitat
scharfschützen dazu sagt er unsere
simulationen zeigen dass jupiter kometen
genauso wahrscheinlich auf die erde
sendet wie sie ablenkt zustimmung kommt
von dem britischen forscher sommers sind
ordner der ebenfalls den einfluss des
jupiter auf die bahnen von asteroiden in
computersimulationen untersucht hat die
große forschungs frage was wäre wenn es
jupiter nicht gäbe gäbe es dann deutlich
mehr einschläge auf der erde mit
katastrophalen konsequenzen
in verschiedenen szenarien ging es um
die flugbahnen von 100.000 objekten die
zwischen jupiter und neptun kreisen
spannend war hier vor allem der
vergleich der flugbahn und wie sich
diese innerhalb von zehn millionen
jahren entwickeln dazu wurden
verschiedene ausgang szenarien gewählt
version 1 jupiter existiert version 2
jupiter fehlt im planetensystem und
version 3 statt jupiter kreist ein
kleiner planet an seiner stelle das
ergebnis der simulation war nicht nur
eindeutig sondern auch überraschend
sogar für das forschungsteam selbst kurz
zusammengefasst ist es demnach nämlich
ganz egal ob jupiter da ist oder nicht
in beiden szenarien
ist es die gleiche anzahl an objekten
die auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
gehen dazu jonathan horne wenn sich an
dieser stelle gar nichts befindet gibt
es keinen unterschied zur jetzigen
impact rate also zur einschlags rate die
erklärung dafür
die meisten objekte des äußeren
sonnensystem zu bleiben brav auf ihren
bahnen wenn es keinen planeten an dieser
stelle gebe wenn jupiter aber existiert
hat seine schwerkraft enorme
auswirkungen und die sind nicht nur
positiv denn zum einen zieht der manche
der objekte damit an und lenkt sie dann
wieder auf neue bahnen die dann
allerdings auch in richtung erde gehen
können doch jupiter sorgt ebenfalls
dafür dass diese wieder weg geschleudert
werden und dabei ganz aus dem
sonnensystem katapultiert werden
anders dagegen wenn statt des gasriesen
ein kleiner planet an seiner stelle
setzt dann würde die anzahl der
anschläge auf der erde deutlich steigen
eine erklärung dafür seine schwerkraft
würde nicht komplett ausreichen um
potenzielle gefährder komplett aus dem
sonnensystem zu bewegen
diese würden somit auf ihrer flugbahn
bleiben die die erde kreuzt daraus
resultiert also dann ein erhöhtes
anschlagsrisiko dieser studie zufolge
wird peter also als eine art
schutzschild doch wenn man genau ist
dann entsteht zumindest ein teil der
gefahr die er abwehrt einzig und allein
durch seine eigene existenz doch kevin
racer geht noch weiter denn er ist sogar
der ansicht dass jupiter nicht nur
indirekt objekte in richtung der ära
katapultieren sondern das sogar aktiv
passiert in seinen modellen präsentieren
der komplexe astrophysikalische prozesse
die zeigen wie weit entfernte
himmelskörper in lokale bedrohung
umgewandelt werden konkret geht es hier
um die sogenannten zentauren asteroiden
die möglicherweise aus dem cooper gürtel
entstanden und die sich zwischen den
umlaufbahnen von neptun und jupiter um
die sonne bewegen
bei einigen zentauren konnte bereits
gefrorenes wasser auf der oberfläche
entdeckt werden genau diese könnten laut
kevin mazur von jupiter in potenziell
kehrt bedrohliche objekte verwandelt
werden denn durch ihn könnten diese ins
innere sonnensystem gelangen und dann
nicht nur auf dem mars oder der venus
sondern auch auf der erde einschlagen
das problem dabei der zentauren handel
sich um schnelle und vor allem auch
große objekte demnach befindet sich die
erde in einem zitat kosmischen
fadenkreuz
die forschenden fordern verstärkt zu
beobachten was weiter entfernt in
jupiters nachbarschaft passiert rätsel
um jupiter gelöst so entstand der planet
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen kanal pixum science in
future bis dann bleib dran ach ja und
hier dann gibt es noch den link zu
unserer telegate gruppe könnte auch dort